Today we are playing a ping pong card game
Each suit represents a different shot
And the number decides the amount
First one to 4 points wins
Okay Emil
Pick a card
Let's see
9 edge shots for the edge guy
Almost missed the first one already
That seems to be easy
You would think the high ones are easy but no
I can't tell are you the edge guy or the ball breaker guy?
Probably both guys in one point!
Okay Otto
What are you hoping for?
Around the nets of course
Why am I even asking you?
Let's see
Jack!
I'm pretty sure you won't get this one!
I have a feeling you are going to make me move now
So far so good
Good!
The last one!
Too bad Otto!
Really gentleman play Emil, nice!
Well done
It was actually nice to see you moving there around quite fast also
I have been practicing my footwork
Going to the fridge
Around the nets - where are they?
There they are!
There we have it!
I'll take one from there
3 edge shots
I'm going to put him some difficult places
1 more!
Nice one!
Thanks
Joker!
You get to choose!
I get to choose the shot
And the amount of shots
Chops!
1 chop
Jack of hearts
Now I'm so happy!
That was a bad ball
What were you saying?
We are over the half way
How is it feeling?
Good so far
Good!
But still can't get too comfortable
Gotta stay focused, 2 more!
That was close! It counts.
That was almost a miss
That's it, 11!
Good one, Otto!
Thank you!
13!
13 behind the backs Emil
Okay this is not gonna go
I already knew from the second shot
Wasn't promising
1 or 14? You get to choose Otto.
But if you choose just one
It has to be an around the net
So it has to be an around the net
Okay
He has it
You get the around the net
4 around the nets
Shouldn't be that big of a problem
On the GoPro
GoPro and the camera!
1 more!
Yes, we have it
There we have it!
I need to find the around the net
I'll use my laser vision
Okay, scroll back!
What did Otto say?
Let's go back!
Chops!
Otto what would have you chosen?
360 degree spin
No-look
Eyes closed
Behind the back
Between the legs
Wrong handed
Penhold
Around the net from under the table
I regret saying anything!
I have a strong feeling that he is not going to make this shot!
I'm quite interested to see how this looks
Did it go in?
Yea, I heard something!
Yea, I think that was perfect!
Okay, between the legs
6 of those
Nice
Doing some good footwork here
Got them!
1 more?
No! That was 6 for sure
I'll go with that one
10 between the legs!
It feels like I need to move again
Let's start it easy and then make him move a bit more
Let's still put some easy ones, good!
And now let's do the hard ones
There it was!
I think that doesn't count anymore!
Yea, I knew it was going to be like that
There is no gentleman rule anymore
Well, this was a fun and interesting game
Something you guys can also try at home
Yea, and remember to subscribe here
And watch our previous episodes there!
Until next time!